Amazon has become the go-to place for
convenient online shopping around the
world it usually only takes a few clicks
to place an order and the item will be
delivered to your doorstep within 48
hours if not 24 hours Amazon's
Relentless push to perfect their
Logistics and bring down delivery times
has put them a league ahead of all the
competition not to mention their
customer service which is generally top
of the line considering Amazon's
convenience speed and variety it's not
surprising that Amazon is able to pull a
nearly 500 billion dollars worth of
Revenue on an annual basis this makes
them the third largest company in the
world by Revenue only be it not by
Walmart and Saudi aramco and honestly
it's just a matter of time until they
become number one with all that being
said though Amazon has a serious quality
control issue now I'm not trying to hit
on Amazon I'm actually a massive fan of
Amazon stock and if you're strictly
buying brand of products from Logitech
or Corsair through Amazon The Experience
is perfect if you're buying unbranded or
private label products however it's a
completely different story more times
than not these products are simply low
quality Chinese products stores through
Alibaba with insane markups to make up
for Amazon's fees shipping marketing and
profit one of the worst offenders on
Amazon is cheap electronics and notably
dongles personally I've experienced this
firsthand with USBC dongles I've gone
through four of these dongles within the
past 21 months they simply stop working
after a couple of months and that
judging by the reviews this is not an
uncommon problem this is honestly super
frustrating because you're selling out
20 to 30 every six months just so you
can plug in your keyboard and mouse to
your computer but when you take a look
at how much it costs to produce these
pieces of trash it's not surprising that
they're so garbage this USBC Hub on
Amazon for example costs 25 dollars the
same product on AliExpress only cost ten
dollars and an even better Hub on
Alibaba only costs 10 to 20 cents and
I'm not cherry picking a dongle either
there are dozens of dongles on Alibaba
that cost just 10 to 20 cents now
granted you do have to make a minimum
order of 200 units on Alibaba but at 20
cents a piece that's only forty dollars
even with international shipping you can
easily get your hands on 200 of these
for less than 100 bucks which is a net
unit cost of less than 50 cents if you
were an Amazon Seller buying thousands
of these you could probably Source them
for 25 cents per unit so when customers
are paying 25 dollars for a product that
only costs 25 cents it's no wonder why
the product does not stack up to their
quality expectations efficient market
hypothesis would tell you that excess
profit margins usually Disappear With
time as more competitors enter the
market these downloads however have
plenty of competition yet all of them
cost 20 20 to 30 dollars so where in the
world is all this money going if not
into the product itself
one of the biggest issues plaguing
Amazon's private label business is
simply how the entire service is
structured usually most private label
businesses use something called an
Amazon FBA this is when you Source
Products from Alibaba and then shipped
inventory directly to Amazon Amazon will
take care of sorting their products
Distributing them Across America and
shipping them to customers with their
insane time frames honestly the fact
that Amazon is able to handle so many
products and ship them to so many people
so quickly is truly a logistics Marvel
but it's also extremely expensive not
only does Amazon charge us the customers
for Amazon Prime or shipping fees but
they also charge Sellers and Amazon FBA
fee right now the absolute smallest fee
that Amazon charges sellers is 3.7 cents
per unit and that's where extremely
small and light objects to be
categorized as a small standard size the
shortest side of the given product has
to be less than three quarters of an
inch fortunately the USB PC cable that
we were looking at would fall under this
definition but there's plenty of small
items that don't take this tiny pot for
example which only measures 2 inches on
every side most of us would classify
this as a small item but Amazon would
actually classify it as a large standard
item and if the product has some heft to
it as in 2-3 pounds sellers can easily
end up paying six dollars and eight
cents per unit and that's simply for a
small item if you're actually selling a
medium-sized item it'll be classified as
an oversized atom for which Amazon will
charge a minimum of 10 per unit sellers
have to pay these fees for every unit
they sell from the back end and they of
course just pass on these fees to us the
customers so really we're paying for
Logistics twice for your average 20
product three to six dollars goes to
paying the Amazon FBA fee and to give in
that most products do not fit within the
small standard size the average fee is
skewed towards six dollars for
Simplicity we'll call it five dollars
average spoiler alert that's just the
first fee Amazon also charges sellers a
referral fee the reason that Amazon FBA
businesses are able to get off the
ground so quickly is because Amazon
already has a massive customer base and
to gain access to this customer base you
have to pay Amazon at eight to fifteen
percent of your total sale price so for
a 20 product this works out to anywhere
between 1.60 cents and three dollars
while estimated in the middle and to
call it two dollars and thirty Cents
Tack this onto the FBA fee and now we're
looking at a total of seven dollars and
thirty cents per unit moving on we have
inventory storage fees this fee is
pretty self-explanatory Amazon charges
sellers to be able to store their
products at Amazon warehouses between
January and September this fee isn't too
bad coming in at 83 cents per cubic feet
but during the holiday months this fee
triples to 2.40 cents per cubic feet on
top of all this Amazon also charges a 40
per month fee for simply being a
professional seller on Amazon on that
wraps up all of the required fees that
all Amazon FBA sellers have to deal with
but some sellers may be subject to
additional fees as well for example when
you ship products to Amazon they want
each product labeled and barcoded in a
specific way you can either pair
supplier to do this which is definitely
a cheaper option or you can pay Amazon
to do this if you want Amazon to do this
or if your supplier did it wrong Amazon
will charge you a minimum of 1.25 cents
per unit additionally sellers are also
subject to a product return fee and
inventory removal fee and other
penalties when you add all of this
together you realize that for an average
20 product the seller is paying Amazon
10 off the top line for Logistics and
seller fees in other words fifty percent
of the products purchase price is not
even going towards the product itself
it's going towards making the part
available on Amazon and then getting it
to you now again I'm not trying to back
on Amazon Logistics especially the way
Amazon closet is expensive but as a
customer just know that this is what
you're really paying for
10 fee for a 20 product is no dot quite
expensive but that still leaves ten
dollars the seller should be able to
spend five dollars on the product and
then profit five dollars right that
would be a win-win scenario Amazon gets
their fees the seller makes their
profits and the customer gets at least a
decent product but the thing that you're
forgetting about is marketing some
bigger private label Brands go out and
run Google ads Facebook ads and even
YouTube ads but by far the most
effective type of marketing is Amazon
ads whenever you search for something on
Amazon you know how the top search
results say sponsored well these aren't
Amazon ads and they're extremely
expensive because they're extremely
effective if you were to see an ad
before this video maybe one in a
thousand of you would actually go buy
the product but whenever you put a
product at the top of Amazon search in
front of people who are already
searching for the product and are ready
to buy the conversion rate goes through
the roof the average conversion rate
across Amazon minus 10 to 15 percent and
the average conversion rate across Prime
members is a mind-boggling at 74 to
capture these insane conversions however
you have to be at the top of Amazon
search sixty percent of all Amazon
sellers go to the first three listings
and eighty percent go to the first page
so if you're launching a new Amazon
product you basically have to pay for
Amazon ads to get any sort of traction
the average cost per click across Amazon
is 89 cents in other words every time
someone clicks on a sponsored listing
the seller has to pay Amazon at 89 cents
and that's just the average I used this
on Amazon myself in moderately
competitive niches and to secure the
first spot in those niches it cost three
dollars per click and it that was back
in 2019 with the influx of online
shopping due to the pandemic I wouldn't
be surprised if that number was closer
to five dollars per click today
especially for something as competitive
as USBC dongles but even if we estimate
conservatively and College at 89 cents
per click if you have a conversion rate
of 10 percent it's gonna cost you 8.90
to move a single unit combine this with
the FBA fees and you'll be paying Amazon
at 18.90 per unit and that's not even
including the cost of the product
realistically though there's no way
you'll only be paying 89 cents per click
especially when you launch if you want
your listing to appear within the top
two response you're likely gonna have to
pay three dollars per click and even if
you have a conversion rate of 20 that
works out to Fifteen dollars per unit
combine this with the FBA fee and your
up to 25 per unit you're five dollars in
the Reddit and you haven't even paid for
the product yet and this is why private
ever products on Amazon are so garbage
given how much sellers have to pay for
FBA and how much they have to pay for
marketing they have no money left to
actually pay for the product itself you
can't feel too bad for the sellers
though because if they do make it to the
other side and rank their product highly
they end up making bank at this point
they can substantially scale back on the
Amazon ads to maybe the average of 89
cents per click if they maintain the 20
conversion rate this comes out to 4.45
cents per click combine this with the
FBA Fiat and they're up to 14.45 cents
per unit if we say the product costs
2.50 per unit they're all on cost is
roughly 17 per unit at a sale price of
twenty dollars they'll be clearing three
dollars on every unit and the top
sellers in the popular nieces generally
sell well over 10 000 units per month
which works out at thirty thousand
dollars per month in profit off of just
one product if you replicate the success
with the 10 products you'll be making
3.6 million dollars per year I think you
can see why Amazon FBA is such a popular
business but in terms of the quality of
their product other times they finish
paying Amazon and themselves there's
nothing left to spend on the product
itself and this is why private label
products on Amazon are so garbage
foreign
the number one thing that we can take
away is that the vast majority of the
purchase price goes directly to Amazon
for a 20 product it's extremely common
for 75 of the proceeds to go to Amazon
between the selling fees at the FDA fees
and the marketing fees but the ironic
part is that Amazon isn't profiting from
any of this either in fact they're
literally losing money within the first
six months of 2022 Amazon lost 5 billion
on their retail business and the main
reason for this is that it's
extraordinarily expensive to pay for
hundreds of thousands of warehouse
workers delivery drivers Pilots planes
trucks ships factories warehouses boxes
boxing materials and everything else
that goes along with Logistics by the
end of it neither Amazon Northern
employees are left with that much money
and customers are left with the trash
products the only people who come out on
top are Amazon shareholders and the
select FBA sellers who make it to the
other side the obvious solution to this
conundrum is to simply spend less money
on Logistics and more money on the
products themselves but with our
increasingly short attention spans this
is simply unfeasible so maybe the
problem isn't Amazon or FBA sellers or
their products themselves maybe the real
problem is actually just our insatiable
desire for instant gratification but
that's just what I think have you had a
bad experience with the Private Label
Amazon product comment that down below
also drop a like if you hoped that
Amazon does something about the quality
issue and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community suggested
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one